so many of us just absolute dread and
fear the possibility of looking fat like
what about this like what if too late it
was okay to have her gut like come out a
little bit no I love that what is like
pretty hot it's like what if what if we
didn't fear fatness the way we do oh
please stop everything is a phobia
42 is just physically unattractive to me
you're fat phobic not even over the
phobia has a contact therapy her muffin
top it's the most ridiculous
no no what you should fear is your heart
giving up on you young ladies don't
listen to these amoebas you're not going
to live a happier life you're going to
live a shorter life you'll die young and
you'll live a lonely life in an
unhealthy life riddled with health
problems it's not a phobia your doctor
is not afraid of you getting fat